yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Jerome Jerome is not playing
actually no he is I can't
please go E 5 oh the bishops opening
yeah Knight f6 what is this sound weird
kind of it delay them anyway so um yeah
that's good 96 therefore why does that
work even I think I can take here right
yeah I think I had this before in some
game yeah this is entirely incorrect of
course for whiten but yeah it's blitz
Jess so how to do it taking here maybe
Queen Queen d5 is that an issue
I can check probably yeah I can check on
you 7
now it's a little bit they're taking us
a little bit to helping you with this
development of course some chat allows
me to check and castle so why does a
pawn down here
does he have compensation here maybe a
little bit yeah actually 95 is 95 is an
idea hmm yeah I mean this is not a good
opening but probably it's enough
compensation in blitz em with this 95
stuff Jim I wonder in hindsight
well Bishop c5 maybe I have to do it to
get cancelled hmm we have it okay this
is this is something probably I haven't
refuted it in the best possible way
okay so what what do I want to plain my
d6 Bishop e6 would be good to get rid of
that Bishop I didn't want to go h6 then
Queen d2 Bishop takes h6s probably just
too easy
one problem for white is that if I go d6
let's say d6 Bishop f6
I'm 35 is a good square for me but okay
that's not relevant anymore after he
went for this this is interesting
it's very forcing
[Music]
yeah after ticks ticks I'm not sure that
I have a good move relay
Jim there should be six and 95 are ways
to play against woogie one cami we have
to check this line I just know that F
force is completely completely bad man
that looks pretty bad but it isn't it
isn't I didn't refute it ready
yeah but now we should have six or
something like that
threatening Queen g5
I mean he has to do something
director thing I mean if I get it should
be 695 and I should be okay yeah Bishop
f6 is interesting I mean I can probably
take it but
well otherwise it just doesn't work
anyway so okay I'm taking us but what is
coming now when rook takes I go Queenie
525 anyway now objectively I'm
completely winning now Bishop f-16 work
I get I get a 95 IQ queen will move
somewhere and I go Queen energy five no
the night comes to you five it's over
that's that that piece is too strong
level by far too strong
quite resigned so let's have a look I
know that I once lost against this
opening and I know that I called it
rubbish back then and I'm sticking with
this I just don't believe that you can
play like that sacrifice a full centre
pawn for relatively little development
advantage okay it takes takes and stop
which gives come in two is seven
hmm yeah that that makes some sense yeah
white cannot cancel
yeah that essentially refutes all thing
if he does this now check I mean here
you would have to go somewhere crazy I
mean this is she training the Queen so
okay I should switch this on I'm sorry
but rusty with all the process them some
of the sisters into work if he goes like
here 98 it looks a tad scary and what
night comes to e6
if I get 96 in 65 and this is coming
with lots of champion you know I tend to
believe the engineer if it if it gives
black a somewhat substantial edge is
probably right
yeah after the capture is this is really
compensation yeah I mean it looked
looked quite scary
this says think I have to do something
like aged six Queen d2 this looks very
scary you know
a computer gives some d5 that that's
possible yeah maybe I can somehow return
the pawn to not being smashed but so
with this these 695 yeah and I have to
defend like I did
Jim the engine doesn't believe it at all
for why Jim read it look - it looks like
compensation to me but if I get Bishop
e6 and all the thing without the engine
is giving here this is kind of the
normal way to play if I get this in and
f6 next and I'm super solid yeah the
night only 5 is just a complete Rock you
know and it simply doesn't work look
cheeks I was expecting this a bit moment
I still have this one and okay he can't
take care of it
it's this is a queen trade
Nadia why the sound of ideas but Queenie
salmon is still stronger how did what
what was the issue then the computer
also thinks that black is better here I
am yeah I wasn't during the game I felt
I was a little it felt scary very really
felt a bit scarier okay yes thanks for
watching